Narrator: Burned Louis Vuitton bags,
chewed-up designer heels,
damaged Chanel handbags,
and worn-out Gucci sneakers:
these accessories have seen better days.
We follow professionals as
they restore nine luxury items.
Our first expert is Rio Jongsae Kim,
from Kim's Shoe & Bag Repair.
He shows us how he mends
these $1,000 Gucci mules,
making them look brand new.
[cloth rustling]
[brush scratching]
I am Charlotte Staerck,
and I'm cofounder and
CEO of Handbag Clinic.
Today, I'm going to walk you through
how our artisan Chloe
will restore this Grand Shopper Tote
that has pen ink all over it.
The Chanel Grand Shopper Tote
reached around 2,000 pounds
when it was able to be
bought direct from Chanel.
When this restoration's complete,
we would sell a Grand Shopper Tote
for anywhere between 1,700 pounds
and 1,950 pounds.
The first thing that Chloe
will do with this item
is remove all of the ink.
The most important part
of restoring this bag
will actually be the initial cleaning,
because ink can spread and
can create more staining.
We use a special ink remover.
So, you can see Chloe
taking the ink remover
with a small cotton bud
and gently rolling this
over the initial ink.
This is so that we don't
have any spreading,
any further contamination
of that ink to the bag.
One of the main reasons for this
is because ink is actually very oily,
and oil and leather really don't mix.
[cotton bud scratching]
We then also use a range of products.
Some are solvent-based,
which will help to dry out any areas
which have absorbed additional oils.
And then we also use products
which have natural oils
embedded into them,
which will then nourish
areas that have dried,
such as the corners or any areas
where the ink has been drawn out of.
[brush rasping]
We then use our specialist
cleaning solution
with the brush and a foam,
which then will remove any excess product.
Caviar skin leather is grained,
so you need the brush to get
into all of those grooves
to be able to really make sure it's clean
and make sure it's ready for
the next stage of the process.
Caviar leather, it gets its name
from being a pebbled-texture leather,
which means that it has printed into it
this almost bubbled effect.
If anything is trapped
there or left in there,
you would run the risk of that
later peeling or coming away.
[airbrush hissing]
Because it is ink that
has contaminated this,
the cleaning process alone
will not remove this stain,
and we must apply other methods.
[airbrush hissing]
In our research and development team,
we realized that ink
stains, in particular,
were very stubborn,
so we created a metallic solution
which actually blocks that coming through
to make sure in a year's time
you're not going to start seeing
that ink stain come through.
Chloe takes the specialist solution
and she applies it
lightly with an airbrush
throughout every area
where you can see the ink.
[airbrush hissing]
Chloe will then create the color match,
which we have discussed
with the client in advance.
[palette knife scraping]
This colorant, once created,
will then be airbrushed on this bag.
We always want to be
as sparing as possible
to ensure the texture of
the leather is maintained.
Because of the iconic CC quilting
and the CC on the front of the item,
which makes this item
the iconic Chanel look,
we want to make sure
as little pigment gets onto
those stitches as possible.
[airbrush hissing]
And the bag is ready to go.
My name is Artem Amirov.
I'm the owner of Royal
Gloss Restoration Studio
here in Russia,
and I'm the head restoration artist there.
Today, I'm going to walk you through
how we restored this $42,000
Celine crocodile bag.
It was made around eight years ago,
and they were producing
it for one year only.
This makes it really rare.
There was a huge amount of problems on it.
There was scuffs and
scratches all over the bag.
The lining inside the bag
was completely messed up.
The bag was missing the
puller for the zipper.
We start with removing the edge paint.
[grinder whirring]
All the edges of the bag
have scuffs and scratches.
We use the grinder to sand it down.
We begin with disassembling the bag.
The inner lining had a lot
of scratches from active use.
As well, it had some dirt stains.
To clean and fix the inner lining,
we had to pull apart all the bag.
The tools that we used were a seam ripper
and a cobbler knife.
The seam ripper is more preferred
for delicate parts of the bag.
We carefully slide under the stitch
and pull the stitch upward to get it out.
The original lining for
Celine crocodile bag
is made of sheepskin.
We also use sheepskin
with the same quality,
with the same color,
and the same softness.
After we carefully took off
all the sheepskin linings
from each side of the bag,
we replaced them with the new ones.
To cut the new lining out,
we use a rotary cutter.
The glue that we use is the
same that the manufacturer use.
It has a very strong bonding.
In order to make a new zipper for our bag,
we use the new zipper.
We use new leather.
We choose a pattern to
match the original scales,
and we paint it the same color as the bag.
In order to clean the handbag,
we use a special leather
shampoo and a semisoft brush.
When we talk about cleaning
the crocodile skin,
it is difficult because
you can damage the patina;
even with a mild cleaner,
you can just wipe it out.
One of the biggest concerns is the scales,
which cracked on the handle.
If it's not prevented in time,
later it will be very
difficult to repair them.
It's also had greasy stains on it,
so in order to remove the stains
and for our paint to
penetrate through the handle
and to have a bond with the surface,
we need to use acetone
to remove the greasy stains.
Applying an edge paint
coat is essential part
to keeping all the edges
sealed and prevent the bag
from further moisture penetration.
To apply the edge paint, we
use a special roller pen.
It grabs a certain amount of edge paint
and allows us to allocate it to the edges.
In order to color match,
I'm testing colors on separate
crocodile leather skin.
I'm trying to mimic the fading
that goes from the center to the edges,
from blue to dark blue
and then to the black.
It gives the bag a very unique look.
In order to apply the paint,
I'm using airbrush and small spray gun.
Working with them allows me
to accurately distribute
paint all over the surface.
We use water-based paints,
which will cover up all the defects.
These kinds of paints have
great adhesion properties.
We had two types of sewing machines
to get the same old stitch holes.
We regulate the length between the holes.
One of the sewing machines
was primarily used
to sew the thickest part of the leather.
We had to be careful with
assembling the bag back together,
because while assembling
all the sides of the bag,
we had to consider the
thickness of the leather layers,
so they won't move during
the sewing process.
For some parts, we did a hand-sewing
to avoid damaging the crocodile leather.
My name is Tom Rago,
and I am the co-owner
of Rago Brothers Shoe & Leather Repair
with my brother, Tony Rago.
And today I am going to walk you through
a dog-chewed Louboutin shoe.
Approximate cost is $800 to $1,000.
When they came in to us,
the platform was halfway chewed off,
the top of the shoe wasn't there,
and the heels were all chewed,
all had bite marks on it.
And you would think that this
was an unrepairable shoe.
We are going to attempt to rebuild
the platform of the shoe,
the upper part, the black patent leather,
and get the structure back to the shoe.
[machine whirring]
To start out the process,
we are going to give this
to our repairman, Ronnie,
who is going to put this shoe together.
[heat gun blowing]
We are using the heat gun
to remove the platform
very carefully, trying to loosen the glue
between the shoe and the platform.
We now are putting the
platform down on the table
and taking a piece of bonded leather
and tracing out the platform
so that we can make a
mold for the other shoe.
[machine whirs]
What that involved is
flipping the platform over
so it looked like a left shoe
instead of the right shoe.
So we did that.
We took our measurements.
Once we've got that pattern,
we now are taking a hard piece of rubber
and we are shaping that with a Dremel
to match the other platform.
The platform, when you
get it from Louboutin,
it's a molded plastic base.
Molded plastic is not available to us,
so we cut it out of a very
rigid piece of rubber,
and we had to sand it to make
the exact curves that it needed to have
to fit the upper part of the shoe.
When you start with the
upper part of the shoe,
you take a flat piece of patent leather
and you take the inside material,
which is a bonded leather --
that gives it the structure.
That gives it the form.
[heat gun blows]
What we're doing now is we're
heating up the leather on the platform
so that we can stretch it,
make it more malleable
so that it has no creases in it.
And then we pull it and
attach it to the platform.
So, now we have the top shape of the shoe.
After we've gotten that,
we begin to form it to
the platform underneath.
[scissors snipping]
We have to mold that platform
around the top of the shoe,
and that requires us using a hand Dremel
to get the shape of the platform
to fit onto the upper part of the shoe.
That's just trial and error.
You may go through that several times.
So, now that we've repaired
the upper part of the shoe,
we're going to take the platform
and attach the platform
to the upper part of the shoe.
Now we are going to give the shoe
to our shoe repairman, Henry,
so that he can attach the
leather and rubber soles
to the bottom of the shoe.
[hammering]
Now what we're doing is
we're attaching the red sole
onto the bottom of the shoe.
We are going to take this shoe,
and we're going to edge
it with black paint,
so that from the side of the shoe
all you see is the black.
You won't see any red.
This shoe was really a challenge for us,
and we think it came out really great.
We think that when the owner
does get this shoe back,
her mouth is gonna drop.
[ripping]
[scraping]
My name is Gerry Gallagher,
master leather craftsman
and founder of Leather Surgeons.
Today we have a black
caviar Chanel classic flap
jumbo bag that's been severely damaged
by an incandescent light bulb.
We had this customer reach out to us.
She did a closet restoration, actually,
and somehow an incandescent light bulb
from a contractor burned its way
clear through her handbag.
Through the outer flap,
through the lining.
But what I'm going to try to do here
is just graft new leather
over the damaged area
and preserve as much of the original
part of the bag as I possibly can.
[chain clicking]
I'm going to start by
opening up all the stitches
around the front flap of the bag.
[ripping]
We're going to use a sewing awl
and a really sharp knife
to be able to just get in between
the lining of the bag
and the shell of the bag
without causing any damage.
I like to pull out the
stitches one at a time,
'cause eventually when we
stitch this bag back together,
we're going to have to stitch
in the same exact holes
that the manufacturer
stitched in the first time.
[ripping]
I'm going to open up the two gusset tacks
so that we can access the
interior lining of the bag,
between the shell and
the lining of the bag,
and see just how much we need to do
as far as replacing the internals.
[ripping]
The burn went completely
through the outer shell
and through the interior
lining of the bag.
[wiping]
[scraping]
For the most challenging part of this job,
we have the damaged area in
the lower right quadrant.
So it will be much easier for me
to take the front panel off
and just recreate the front panel.
But what I'd like to do
is preserve as much of
the front panel of the
bag as I possibly can
and just replace the part that's damaged.
So I'm going take my
knife and I'm going to
very carefully skive off,
which means cut away,
the existing leather
that's burned or damaged.
I'm going to make our little pattern,
and I'm going to replace
that piece of leather.
I use a pattern to cut the
size of the front panel
and make sure it's 100% accurate.
Because the bag was so severely damaged
and it was burned completely through,
and actually clear through
the interior lining,
I'm going to cut fresh lining panels.
We have patterns already precut
for this particular bag.
The interior lining of
the bag is made of goat,
so we replace it with goat.
As far as Chanel, this bag
is Chanel caviar leather,
which we also stock.
We're able to replace
everything about this bag
exactly the way it was
done the first time.
I'm going to take that
piece of caviar leather
and I'm going to hand-skive it,
which means shave it down.
If I skive the leather paper-thin
and I lay it right along that line,
when I drop my new stitch over that seam,
there'll be zero transition between
what was there before
and what we have now.
It should completely disappear.
I'm gonna lie and cement
that piece of leather
right over that seam.
This a traditional leather contact cement,
so you need to apply the
cement to both surfaces
and give it a minute or two to set
and then press the pieces together.
[sewing machine clicking]
When you're doing a restoration
and you want to put the stitch back in
the stitch hole that was there before,
you need to aim the needle for the hole.
So when I requilt this leather,
any stitches that are visible,
I have to make sure I drop the stitch
in the same exact hole.
[sewing machine clicking]
It's just a question of
measuring everything out.
Because the flap quilting has to match
the body of the bag quilting.
When you close that bag,
all of those seams should line up.
[sewing machine clicking]
Now we're going to unweave
the leather of the chain.
This customer felt that
the patina on the gold
was starting to fade a little bit,
so we replate the metal.
Then I'm going to reweave
that leather through the chain
and stitch the two ends.
I feel really good about
what we did here today.
We took a bag that would've
otherwise been trashed,
and we gave it a new lease on life.
I'm Taleen Akopyan,
cofounder of Purse Rehab.
We are a designer-handbag- and
leather-goods-restoration company.
Today, I'm going to walk you through
how my team restores
a burned Louis Vuitton Neverfull bag.
This is the Damier Ebene Neverfull print.
It's their top-selling bag today.
This bag is about $2,000,
depending on the size.
Unfortunately, the bag
was left, by accident,
on a burning electric stovetop.
So the entire base is basically burned,
along with the piping,
and the side of the bag is also burned.
To start, we're going
to unstitch the base.
And in order to do that,
we're using a round awl
to remove the stitching
and remove the piping as well.
We're going to clean off
some of the debris here
using a soft-bristled brush.
This is a coated canvas bag.
Basically, coated canvas is cotton
that's coated with polyvinyl chloride.
So that's why you have that black color
and the hardness of the canvas.
Now we are drawing the template
using the base that we removed.
And we are using cowhide leather.
This is premium leather
that matches the existing trim on the bag.
We're going to also skive
the base at the edges.
Skiving is essentially
shaving down the leather,
and it's usually done at the edges
so that they're easily
foldable or stitchable.
To match the interior
red canvas of the bag,
we are cutting a new piece of red material
to glue on and stitch onto the base
so that the interior is fully compatible
with the existing lining.
And it's very much like
the Louis Vuitton material.
We have to make a new
piping to add to the base.
This is made out of the same leather.
And so we cut out the piping
and glue it onto the base.
And, in addition to gluing it,
we will also be stitching the piping
so that it's double reinforcement.
Simply gluing it isn't going to give it
that extra strength that it needs,
because it is a base, so it's
a stress point on the bag.
In addition to making the base,
we are going to recreate the burned piece
that's on the side of the bag.
We are using recycled
Louis Vuitton material
that's in the Damier Ebene print,
so that it looks more seamless
and it blends in nicely with the bag.
We try to align the pattern
on the bag first visually,
to make sure that we can make it fit.
Once we cut it, we are going to glue it
onto the canvas and also stitch it.
And once the recycled piece is on the bag,
we're going to trim off
the excess burned portion
that's underneath the bag.
Once we've completed the
preparation of the new base,
it's time to put it on the bag.
First, we glue it onto the
bag using leather glue,
and then we are stapling the base
onto the body of the bag.
It's a unique feature that
our craftsmen use here
so that when we're stitching it together,
it's solid and it doesn't move.
Once we're done stitching
the base onto the bag,
we are removing the staples
using a round-tipped staple remover,
which does not damage the
canvas or the leather.
Once we're done with the structural issues
and the repairs on the bag,
we're cleaning it using a mild cleaner
to revitalize and condition the canvas.
It would've been impossible for us
to match the exact same
pattern and material.
We did our best to come up with a solution
that does blend well with the bag
and makes it usable in the long run.
And that, essentially,
was our client's goal.
My name's Freya Bass, and I own Bagsamoré,
a handbag-restoration
company in Sydney, Australia.
Today, I'm going to walk you through
how I restore a $4,000 Chanel vanity case.
Typical of a bag of this age,
the lining is disintegrating,
as it is a coated fabric.
We also have wear and
tear to the outer corners.
This bag was purchased
10 years ago for $1,500.
It is today worth between
$3,000 and $5,000,
so in its restored state,
it will be worth more towards $5,000.
To begin the process,
I'm going to remove
the strap from the bag.
So I'm going to do this
using some small pliers
to gently remove the chain from the link.
The strap is very worn.
So there is color wear, dirt, buildup,
and the metalwork is tarnished.
I'm then going to take a quick unpick
and undo the stitches
at the end of the chain.
I now need to unthread the
leather through the chain
so that it's completely
separated from the metalwork.
Now I've fully removed the
leather from the chain,
I'm going to clean the strap.
So the leather strap will just be cleaned
initially with foam cleaner.
I'm doing this with a
horsehair hide brush,
which is nice and gentle
to get into the grain of the leather.
And then I'm going to
continue this process
throughout the exterior of the bag.
So I'm just applying foam
cleaner to the bag's surface,
doing one panel at a time.
I'm gently massaging the foam
into the grain of the leather.
It's always important to clean the bag
before applying pigment.
This will mean that the pigment
will bond to the leather better.
If there's anything left
on the surface of the bag,
such as silicones from protector sprays
or day-to-day dirt buildup,
this could hinder the bonding process.
Now I'm going to clean
the interior of the bag.
I just need to clean as much
of the debris away as possible.
So I'm using a much more
gentle cleaner here,
which is like a luxury leather cleaner.
So it's a water-based cleaner,
and I'm basically just
going to gently wipe
inside the lining.
This has to be done really gently,
as if any pressure is put on
or if a product that
was incorrect was used,
it will then start to remove
even more of the lining.
We need to preserve
as much of the original lining as possible
to make the job easier
in the restoring stage.
Now we've fully cleaned
the bag inside and out,
I'm going to move over
to the repair process.
The interior of the bag is disintegrating.
This is quite common with this age bag,
as it was made from a coated fabric.
Over time and due to humidity,
the surface of the lining
will start to crumble and come away.
We need to restore the lining
as close to the original as possible,
so we're going to rebuild the surface
using fillers and pigments.
So here I'm going to
use a flexible filler.
This filler moves with the
surface of the leather or fabric.
So I'm just going to apply this
using a very soft and small paintbrush
so I can get a nice even surface
across the whole interior lining.
The idea is to restore the original
and avoid having to replace
something like this.
This means we retain the
original Chanel logo.
I'm going to do this
very slowly to make sure
that I get a good even
coverage all the way around.
I'm going to start using
the filler along the top rim
and then work my way down
into the main crevices of the lining.
Once applied, this filler
needs 24 hours to cure.
Now I've left the filler for 24 hours,
I'm sanding down the surface.
This is to remove any
sort of bits of grain
or lumps or bumps and try
and get a smooth finish.
I'm just going to start sanding
around the top really gently.
I'm using a very fine sandpaper
so it doesn't grab or wear down
the surface of the original lining.
And I'm then going to wipe
over with some alcohol.
This will remove any of the surface dust
that has been created from the sandpaper,
and then it will also
slightly soften the filler
to help it smooth
and blend into the original
surface of the lining.
Before airbrushing, I'm just going to
remove the CC lock hardware.
This makes it much easier
to get an even coat around the lock.
I'm just going to unscrew this
with a small flat-head screwdriver.
Once I've removed that,
I'm going to tape up the
remaining hardware on the bag.
So now I'm just going to move on
to mixing a color for the bag.
I custom-mix every color by eye,
so I tend to use about
three or four paints
to mix each color.
So here I'm using caramel,
gold yellow, and citrine.
I mix these together,
and I'm just going to test the color
on a small area on the bag
to make sure it matches.
This can take few attempts sometimes
just to make sure that the
color is absolutely spot on.
Now I've got my color, and I'm good to go.
I'm just going to pop it into an airbrush.
I use the airbrush, as it allows me
to create lots of fine coats of pigment
rather than painting it on,
which would go on too thick.
It's really important not
to too-heavy-coat a bag
with paints, pigments, and fillers.
Less is always more.
So we still want to preserve the original
look and feel of the bag.
I'm just going to work my way
round each section of the bag,
concentrating on the
areas that have more wear.
Now I've managed to get
a nice coat of pigment
over all of the bag,
I'm then going to use a finish.
A finish is a clear-coat sealant
which goes on top of the pigment
to protect it from wear and tear.
Here I've mixed about
two-thirds high gloss
to a third matte to
get a nice satin sheen,
which reflects the original leather.
I'm just going to airbrush
this finish over the whole bag
and then leave it to dry.
Now moving on to the leather in the strap,
I'm actually going to paint
this on with a paintbrush
so as not to have too much wasted paint.
So I'm just going to run
all the way along the strap with one coat,
leave it to dry, and
then repeat the process.
I'm then going to finish this off,
again, with airbrushing the finish
for a nice even layer
across the whole strap.
Now I'm going to move on to the lining.
I'm going to take my
paintbrush and paint in
over all of the areas where
the surface had chipped away.
This may take a few coats,
as it was showing white underneath,
but I need to rebuild the color back up
to match the surface lining.
Once I've done that, I'm
going to apply a finish.
Due to the severity of the
condition of this lining,
there will still remain
a few imperfections,
but what we've done is we
sealed and recoated the surface,
so this will prevent any
further damage from happening
and give this handbag a new lease on life.
Now that I've completed
all of the airbrushing,
I am now going to polish the hardware.
Here I'm going to use a
fine-grade metal polish
to just gently polish
the surface of the metal.
This'll remove any of the tarnishing.
As I'm doing so, you
can see the dark color
of the tarnished metalwork
coming off onto the cotton bud.
I'm going to polish all
of the links on this strap
to bring them up to a nice shiny gold.
Now all the color work is done,
I'm going to reattach the strap.
I'm going to, firstly,
re-thread the leather through the strap.
It's really important that you
line the leather up properly
so that you get the same amount each end.
I am now using the pliers
to reattach the chain to the bag.
Now I need to stitch the
leather back together
through the original holes.
I'm taking some matching-color thread
and using a very fine needle
so I can get through the original holes.
It's really important to go
through the original holes,
as if you make a new hole in leather,
there's no way of reversing that
without then going through
another repair process.
I'm just going to secure
with a couple of stitches
and then tie it in on
itself to keep it neat.
And now I just need to thread the end
back through the leather
and then secure it with
a little bit of glue,
just like it was originally done.
And now I'm going to
apply a leather protector
to the surface of the leather.
This will protect the bag
from dye transfer from jeans,
UV damage, and liquid and oil staining.
It's really important to
protect your leather bags
for future wear and tear.
I'm really happy how the
restoration of this bag turned out.
The interior is now ready to be worn,
and the lining is all fixed up.
The outside is no longer showing
any signs of wear and tear,
and the gold hardware is
looking nice and shiny.
I think my customer is going to be
really pleased with the outcome.